The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional material from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today we're going to start
the last section.
We're going to do three lectures
on phase diagrams.
And I've given this the label
here of Stability, Sustaining
the Solid State.
We've talked a lot about the
solid state in 3.091 as the
vehicle for teaching the
rudiments of chemistry.
One of the things we have not
talked about, is what are the
conditions that sustain
the solid state?
How do I know whether
something's going to be a
solid, or a liquid, or a gas?
This is very important.
For example, if you're in a
foundry, you're running
places, making auto parts,
you have to know what the
solidification temperature is of
the alloys, so you can get
the parts out quickly and
keep productivity high.
It's even important in
failure analysis.
You know, when they were looking
at things like the
rubble from the World Trade
Center by understanding phase
stability, the thermal history
was imprinted in the metal.
It's possible to determine
what temperatures were
achieved, and therefore, what
the chain of events was that
led to the collapse of
those buildings.
Now you might say, well, isn't
this straightforward?
I mean, for example, you just
look up the melting point or
boiling point.
Water, 0 degrees C. Melting
point, boiling point, 100
degrees C.
Well, suppose you decide to
realize your life's ambition.
You're going to go and
scale Mount Everest.
So you pay the $10,000, you
get a license from the
Nepalese Government,
and you're at base
camp at 20,000 feet.
You're sitting there, you've
got your campfire going,
you've got a hankering for
a hard-boiled egg.
And you start, you put the eggs
into boiling water and
you cook them 10 minutes, you
take them out, and they're
still runny.
You say, I must've lost
track of time.
So you cook them 20 minutes,
and they're still runny.
And you cook them 30 minutes,
And you eventually come to the
realization that at 20,000
feet, the boiling point of water
is below the denaturing
temperature of egg yolk.
So now the boiling point is
a function of pressure.
So you know, we could have one
of these Iron Chef cookoffs,
only the dish is souffle, only
we'll have the contest at
Flagstaff, Arizona, where the
altitude is so high that the
classical recipes won't work,
because the boiling point, the
atmospheric pressure, and
everything conspire so that
you're not going to be able
to support the souffle.
So you're going to have to
understand phase diagrams.
In fact, if you understand phase
diagrams, that's your
ticket to being a four-star
chef in the kitchen.
Well, here's another place we
can look at, where pressure
has an important role.
Let's look under the
hood of a car.
You're running an internal
combustion engine.
So this is the engine
block, and there's
combustion going on inside.
We've got to keep this thing
from overeating.
It could damage the metal.
In extreme, you could
melt the metal.
So we've got cooling channels
in here with water flow.
But then the water's going
to heat up, and the
water's going to boil.
So we've got, over here,
the radiator.
So it's really a double
cooling system.
The water cools the block,
and then the
radiator cools the water.
So how's that going to work?
Well, here, the temperature is
on the order of about 90
degrees C, and here the
temperature inside the engine
block is much greater than 90
degrees C. It's several
hundred degrees C inside that
engine block, and we've got
water going like this.
So we've got cooling water
flow in this manner.
And now cold water goes in and
hot water comes out, and then
we get into the radiator, and
we've got channels here, and
we've either got a fan or
some kind of air flow.
And so now, what's
the gambit here?
I want to see what's going
on inside this radiator.
So if this is the wall of the
radiator, and in here I've got
water, and over here I've got
air, the idea is to have a
high heat flux to get the energy
out of the water and
cool it down.
Now, if things get really,
really hot in here-- let's say
you're zooming along down the
highway at about 90, I mean,
about 65 miles an hour, and all
of a sudden you come upon
a collision, and you have to
go to a dead stop, all that
energy in the engine
is now dumped, and
the water could overheat.
And in the extreme, if it
overheats, it can actually go
into a boil.
And this is bad.
Because heat transfer is really
good between a liquid
and a solid, and it's
really poor
between a gas and a solid.
This is a low heat flux,
and this is bad.
High heat flux, that's good.
This is the bubbles.
This is boiling.
And why?
Because what transfers energy?
It's the atoms.
And what's the atom density in
a liquid versus the atom
density in a gas?
You just have really crummy
heat transfer.
That's why insulation involves
dead airspace.
Because you have very
poor atom density.
So what can we do in
order to try to
repress the bubble formation?
Well, we said if we went up
Mount Everest, we went to high
altitude, the boiling
point went down.
And why did it go down?
Because the atmospheric
pressure is lower.
So why don't we go the inverse
here, and we'll put a pressure
cap on the radiator, and make
the pressure go up, and when
the pressure goes up, it exerts
a back pressure and
represses bubble formation?
So by increasing pressure, we
can increase the temperature,
and get the temperature up.
So let's say p equals-- if you
look on the top of the
pressure cap, it will
say 15 psi.
And 15 psi is almost 14.7 psi,
which is exactly 1 atmosphere,
which in SI units is, and I know
this to six significant
figures, 101325 Pascals.
Or, you know, from Torricelli,
760 millimeters of mercury,
that's the column that's
supported.
So we're at 2 atmospheres
pressure in there, and with
two atmospheres of pressure, we
can raise the boiling point
to 106 degrees C. And then what
we can do, is now change
the composition.
So we change the pressure, and
I change the boiling point.
I change the composition.
add 50% ethylene glycol.
So now I've got a
one-to-one mix,
ethylene glycol and water.
And that takes the boiling point
up to 130 degrees C, or
265 degrees Fahrenheit.
So another example of how
we can manage systems.
So when I'm showing you by these
several examples, is
that the boiling point is a
function of pressure and
composition.
So we can tune the
boiling point.
See we were tuning materials
properties before.
Now we're tuning physical
chemical properties, because
that's what chemistry
is all about.
It's about control.
It's about management.
Management to advantage.
So how do we know
what to do here?
Can we predict this from
first principles?
No.
Systems are still
too complicated.
Our models aren't
robust enough.
So instead, we turn
to an archive.
So we have phase diagrams.
And the phase diagrams guide
us in our search for better
management of material
systems.
And these are stability maps.
They tell us which phases are
stable under which conditions
of pressure, temperature,
composition.
You can consider them
as archives.
So that's what I want to talk
about, because it's really
important to know this stuff.
OK.
So what are we going to do?
So first of all, let's--
I don't want to write
on that one.
This is interesting.
This could be a work of art.
I'd hate to desecrate it.
You like?
This is really good!
So I'm just going
to leave that.
That's very good.
That's excellent.
OK.
So I've been talking
about phase.
What is a phase?
Let's get the right
definition here.
What is a phase?
It's a region uniform chemical
composition.
Just to get it down.
it's a region in a material,
region of uniform chemical
composition, and it has these
other properties.
Uniform chemical composition.
It's physically distinct.
And I'll show you by examples,
but let's just get the
definition down.
It's physically distinct, and
in the extreme case--
so that means it's bounded.
It's physically distinct.
That's a fancy way of saying
that you can put a
boundary around it.
It's bounded.
And then the other property that
it has, it's mechanically
separable in the extreme.
And so that's in the
case where you have
a multi-phase system.
You can point to the
different p.
So what I'm going to
do, is I'm going to
give you some examples.
And so I'm going to let circle
p equal number of phases.
I'll give you some examples.
Why am I using circle p?
Because just plain old p
is already pressure.
So pressure, so this is kind of
a Western motif, you know?
Like a Circle Bar Ranch
or something.
So it's a p with a circle.
That's my font.
That's how I say number
of phases.
So let's take a look
at some examples.
So here's some examples
of p equals 1.
So simple one is pure water.
Pure H2O liquid.
It has all of this.
Wherever I have the water, all
right, here's some water, it's
all of the same chemical
composition.
It is physically distinct.
I can put a boundary
around it.
And in this case, there's
nothing to separate, because
it's just a one-phase system.
White gold.
White gold is one phase.
Because we have gold.
Obviously we have gold.
If you market something as white
gold, it has no gold,
you'll go to prison.
And how do we make white gold go
to its white color from the
normal yellow?
We add silver and
we add nickel.
And these are all FCC metals,
and they substitute for one
another on the lattice, and if
you sample anywhere in the
white gold, you get
the same chemical
composition, and so on.
Air is an example of
a one-phase system.
It's a gas, and in decreasing
order, we
have nitrogen, oxygen.
So it's a solution.
We're breathing a solution.
Nitrogen, oxygen, argon are
the main constituents.
There's some CO2, some sulfur
dioxide if you live near a
power plant, NOx if you're
near a tailpipe, and
so on and so forth.
And then the last one I'll
give as an example is
calcia-zirconia.
Or cubic zirconia.
Let's just call it
cubic zirconia.
The holidays are coming,
so we better get
cubic zirconia up here.
That's the poor man's diamond.
Cubic zirconia, which consists
of a solid solution of calcium
oxide in zirconium oxide.
This is a solid solution, so
it's continuous and chemical
composition identical.
Now, contrast that with
two-phase system.
So p equals 2 looks like this.
So let's look at, instead of
simple water liquid, if I have
ice cubes in water.
So now I have two different
phases, and they're separated
by state of matter.
State of matter is
the issue here.
Because I have a solid--
this is solid--
and I'm going to put the
boundary around them.
The composition of the solid
is different from the
composition of liquid.
They're both the same water,
but you can tell it's a
different crystal structure
and so on.
And I can put boundaries
around, and it's
mechanically separable.
You can pull the ice cubes
out of the mix.
Milk is two-phase.
Milk has a fatty phase and
it has an aqueous phase.
The aqueous phase contains
the minerals.
That's why you can drink skim
milk and still get your
calcium, because calcium, even
the general public knows
calcium is a mineral.
It's not elemental calcium,
it's a calcium compound.
But it's ionic, it's soluble in
water, and the fat contains
the other parts.
You know from last day, this
is one of the lipids.
And so you have fat globules
that are mechanically
separable and distinct
from aqueous.
So they actually have
a different chemical
composition, different
type of bonding.
Right?
This is largely nonpolar, and
nonpolar doesn't like to
dissolve in something that is
polar and hydrogen-bonded.
So they phase separate.
I've been saying phase
separate all along.
Now you know what we mean
by phase separate.
Here's a third one.
This is really cool, because
you won't get this in any
other chemistry class,
because only 3.091
talks about such things.
David, can we cut to the
document camera?
I want to show you a piece
of snowflake obsidian.
Obsidian is a volcanic glass.
So here's the piece
of obsidian.
And what you're looking at is,
the black area is the glassy
part, and the white is actually
some of the obsidian
that has decided to devitrify.
And it is turning crystalline.
And so those are islands of
obsidian crystal sitting in a
matrix of obsidian glass.
If we go back to the--
I picked that up in
Yellowstone Park.
It's fantastic.
There's a wall, just a wall of
obsidian that comes down.
And I think I've got
an image here.
There it is.
This one I pulled off
the internet.
So this is crystalline
phase, and this is
the amorphous phase.
And the overall composition,
it's a glass, it's a silicate.
And why isn't it transparent
to visible light?
Because it's got iron in it.
The iron gives it the absorption
and capabilities.
The band gap is invisible,
so it's black.
But then when this crystallizes,
it's got a
different index, and
it's mainly SiO2.
It's really the cristobalite
phase of the obsidian.
So that's cool.
So this is actually
differentiated on the basis of
amorphous and crystalline of
something that's virtually the
same chemical composition.
So this could give you an idea
of what happens in the area of
phase separation.
OK.
Now the second thing that
I have to bring to your
attention, is that these phase
diagrams treat systems at
equilibrium.
They're stability maps, and
they treat systems at
equilibrium.
So what is equilibrium?
Let's just get one time up
here a definition of
equilibrium.
Equilibrium is a condition which
there is no net reaction
taking place.
The system could be reacting.
If you're looking at the ice
cubes in water, the ice could
be dissolving, and some of the
water could be freezing, but
overall, with time, there's
no net reaction.
It's a dynamic system with
And it's characterized as
the lowest energy state.
Systems strive towards
equilibrium.
If it's the lowest energy state,
no net reaction then.
If a system is truly at
equilibrium, the properties
should be invariant
over time, because
there's no net reaction.
You can't prove equilibrium.
You can only demonstrate the
absence of equilibrium.
Because at equilibrium, there's
nothing, there's no
net reaction.
And it could be attainable
by multiple paths.
So in other words, if I have ice
as the equilibrium phase,
I can make it by freezing water,
and get to the same ice
at the given temperature
and pressure.
Or I could sublime.
But if I specify the pressure
and the composition, I should
always end up with
the same system.
So attainable by
multiple paths.
Because it's a stable
state, so it doesn't
matter how you got there.
It's a state function.
And you know from your physics,
a state function has
the same value, regardless
of how you arrived there.
And then the last thing is,
I want to differentiate.
See, these are all single phase,
but some of them are
just one element, some of them
are just one compound, and
some of them have a whole mix.
So we have a way of quantifying
the degree of
chemical complexity by using
the term called component.
It's a measure of chemical
complexity.
It's the number of chemically
distinguishable constituents.
And again, these are
definitions.
I'll give you some examples
so then the
definition comes to life.
I like to think of it as the
number of bottles you've got
to pull off the shelf to
make the final product.
The building blocks.
So for example, water
is just water.
You could say, but it's
hydrogen and oxygen.
But if you take 560 or some
other thermal class, you'll
learn that they're bound
by mole ratio.
You don't have freedom of
hydrogen and oxygen.
So it's just one bottle, whereas
to make white gold,
you need three bottles.
You need a bottle of gold,
a bottle of silver,
and a bottle of nickel.
So that's a three component
system.
And I'm going to designate the
components by c with a
circle around it.
Because c without a circle
is already composition,
concentration.
OK.
So now we can put all of this
together, and we'll show the
difference between
multicomponent and multiphase.
So we'll make a little table
here, and here I'm going to
talk about one-phase systems,
and distinguish on the basis
of components.
So if it's single phase single
component, that's just water.
One phase, one component.
Simple liquid.
If it's two components one
phase, that could be
calcia-zirconia.
I need a bottle of calcia and a
bottle of zirconia in order
to make this two component
single-phase system.
And then to have three
components,
that's the white gold.
It's still single phase, but I
need the gold, silver, and the
nickel, whereas if I come over
here, I've got two phases.
That could be slush.
Slush, that's ice water.
It's just one component.
I just start with water, and
drop it down to 0 Centigrade,
and I'm going to end up with
ice crystals in the water.
So that's one component.
I just needed one bottle.
Literally, one bottle.
All right.
Now what about two components,
two phases?
Well, we saw earlier when we
started thinking about
solubility, we did the
bilayer with carbon
tetrachloride and water.
Remember, we dropped potassium
permanganate and iodine, and
the potassium permanganate
dissolved in the water, and
the iodine dissolved in the
carbon tetrachloride?
Two different components.
I need a bottle of carbon tet
and a bottle of water.
And they'll phase separate.
They don't dissolve in one
another, because this is a
nonpolar liquid, and this is
polar hydrogen bonded.
That's the origin of
phase separation.
It's all about bonding, and
bonding is all about
electronic structure, and that
sounds like a good topic for a
class in chemistry.
And then the last one
here is obsidian.
The snowflake obsidian,
in which the
components are SiO2--
so I'm going to have three
components and
end up with two phases.
SiO2, there's some magnesia, and
then the black comes from
the magnetite.
Fe304.
So I've got three bottles off
the shelf, and I end up with
something that is crystalline
and amorphous.
So that's where I get
the two phases.
Three components, two phases.
It's great.
So now I want to look at
some stability maps.
And I'm going to start with the
simplest of all, which is
the one we know best from human
experience, and that's water.
So we're going to look
at the one--
so it's a one component.
So for water, we start with c
equals 1, and the example is
going to be water.
One component phase diagram.
So we don't have a composition
axis, because the only thing
we can vary is pressure
and temperature.
If we change composition,
we've lost water.
So it has to be axiomatically,
no variation composition.
All we have is that
the coordinates of
temperature and pressure.
So there it is out of the book,
and I'm going to draw it
a little bit differently, just
to emphasize three of my
favorite words.
Not to scale.
Otherwise you can't see some
of the subtle features.
So overall, it's a
y-shaped diagram.
And this is pressure.
Let's make it pressure
in atmospheres.
Then our human experiences
is at 1 atmosphere.
So at the highest temperatures,
we expect to
have vapor, and at the lowest
temperatures, we expect solid.
And in between, we
expect liquid.
And then if we look at the 1
atmosphere isobar, what's
happening on this line?
On the one side of line it's
liquid, and the other side of
line, it's vapor.
At this temperature, liquid
and vapor coexist.
I call that the boiling point.
So I'm going to put 100 here.
And we already learned from our
little example of Mount
Everest that this locust here,
this line, is the liquid
equals vapor two phase
equilibrium.
And you see how it changes?
If I go to the top of Mount
Everest, the pressure is less
than 1 atmosphere.
which means the boiling point
of water is below the
denaturing point.
So this actually gives
you the map.
Or if I put the pressure
cap on, I go up here.
And you can use this in
the kitchen again.
If you love wild rice, and you
can't wait 45 minutes when you
get home, use a pressure
cooker.
What the pressure cooker does,
is it allows you to have
liquid up to 130 degrees
Celsius.
See, you can't steam it.
You've got to soak
it in water.
And you know the
Arrhenius Law.
If you can get the temperature
up by 30 degrees, you'll cut
the cooking time in half.
So how do you get water,
liquid, at 130 degrees?
Then you can cook quicker!
Pressure.
Seal it.
And then you've got liquid
water way, way up here.
Now over here, this is
solid goes to liquid.
So this is the freezing
point line.
At 1 atmosphere, that's 0.
0 Celsius.
And you know, if you
go skating--
so let's say the ice
is minus 5 Celsius.
And you're here, but you put
your weight on the blades, and
the blades have small area.
So pressure is force per area.
So that puts you up here, and
now you cross, and now you
glide on water.
Film of water.
You ever watch a hockey game?
I grew up in Canada.
We used to say, well,
the ice is fast.
Why is the ice fast?
Because you get down to
temperatures where you just
get the right slickness
of water.
If the ice is slow, the
temperature is so close that,
you know, you get these big,
bruising hockey players, and
they're moving up into
here, and it's
like they're dragging.
And if you ever come from
Minnesota or North Dakota, if
you've ever skated when the
temperature gets down about
minus 20, minus 30?
It's a different experience,
because you never
get across this line.
Your blades are just, they
can't get a good grip.
See?
Everything you need
to know is here.
This is four-star chef, this is
prize-winning hockey player.
We haven't got off the 1
atmosphere line yet.
OK.
So now I'm going to say, this
is single phase, right?
It's just vapor.
This is single phase, and
this is single phase.
It's all solid.
And along this line, it's
two phase, isn't it?
Solid-liquid.
This is ice cubes, isn't it.
Anywhere along this line
is ice cubes in water.
Look at this one.
This is liquid vapor.
This is solid, liquid--
all three of them
coexist here.
This is p equals 3, which means,
ice cubes floating in
boiling water.
And this happens at
only one point.
It's called the triple point,
and its coordinates are--
this is not to scale.
So this is 0.01 degrees
C. It's a
1/100 of a degree higher.
And the pressure here is 4.58
millimeters of mercury, which
then you can convert using
the 760 as 1 atmosphere.
Oh, and this is solid-vapor.
You can go directly from solid
to vapor down here.
If you hang up your clothes on
a line and it's minus 20
degrees outside, first
thing that
happens, the clothes freeze.
You come back five
hours later, and
the clothes are dry.
Well, what happened?
Did somebody take them in?
Run them around the clothes
dryer, then
hang them up for you?
No.
You're going directly from solid
to vapor, down in here.
So here's the whole story
of the phase diagram.
One last thing I want
to point out.
Here, you're at a given
temperature and it's vapor.
And then you squeeze, squeeze,
squeeze, and now things get
closer together, and you go
from paper to liquid at
constant temperature.
That makes sense, right?
I start from vapor, constant
temperature.
I squeeze it, I get liquid,
I keep squeezing,
I should make solid.
Here's vapor.
I squeeze, I get solid,
and I squeeze
harder, and I get liquid.
That makes no sense at all,
but that's what happens.
What does this tell me?
It tells me that the number of
nearest neighbors in the solid
is greater than the vapor.
Yeah, I get that.
But the number of nearest
neighbors in the liquid must
be greater than the
number of nearest
neighbors in the solid.
This is an exception.
When I see this negative slope,
it means that ice cubes
are going to float on water.
That's what I learn from
this negative slope.
So let's put that down.
dp by dt when dp by dt
is less than zero.
This is for solid
equals liquid.
That means that the density of
the solid is less than the
density of the liquid.
All from here.
OK.
Good.
So let's look at a few
other phase diagrams.
I think I've got a few
things up here.
Here's silicon.
Pressure versus temperature.
Its normal melting
point is about--
see, now I said normal
melting point.
After today's lecture, if
somebody says, what's the
boiling point of water?
You don't go, 100 degrees.
You say, at what pressure?
And they go, oh, I hate you.
I hated you before.
I'm going to use
an adverb here.
Now I really hate you.
OK.
So this is the normal melting
point of silicon.
It's about 1430 degrees
Centigrade, or a 1700
something Kelvin.
And it also has this
negative slope.
And what does that tell you?
That liquid silicon is denser
than solid silicon, and it's a
good thing it is, because
we wouldn't have the
microelectronics age if
it weren't for that.
We couldn't have Teukolsky
crystal growth and everything
else that makes silicon
dirt cheap.
You know why it's dirt cheap?
Because it's made from dirt.
That's why it's dirt cheap.
It's true.
Here's aluminum.
This is normal.
This is the normal solid-liquid
equilibrium.
This is FCC metal, which
is the closest packed.
Axiomatically, the liquid must
be less well-packed.
All right?
So this is dog bites man,
this is man bites dog.
This is the unusual one.
OK.
What else do we have?
Nitrogen!
Here's nitrogen.
I drew this.
So there's the 1 atmosphere
line.
Nitrogen boils at 77
Kelvin, and it
freezes at about 63 Kelvin.
And it's got the positive slope
that you'd expect, and
so solid nitrogen is denser
then liquid nitrogen.
And you can remember
77 Kelvin.
You want to remember a
few of these things.
I wanted to point out to
you that at atmospheric
temperature, ambient
temperature, you
can remember 20-20.
20-20 vision.
So at 20 degrees C, it's roughly
20 millimeters of
mercury, is the vapor
pressure of water.
It's not exactly true, but
it's close enough.
I think it's really 24.
But 20-20 is nice to know.
And what's the street
address for MIT?
77 Mass Ave. That's the boiling
point of liquid
nitrogen, 77 Kelvin.
So I thought we'd do
a few things here.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit of fun and games
with liquid nitrogen.
But first, I've been instructed
I have to practice
safe laboratory--
So I'm going to put
on my lab coat.
Yes.
It's a nice lab coat.
Mm-hm!
Yeah, look.
You want to know--
let's go back to this.
They have to know where
the-- this is not
just any old lab coat.
This is a nice lab coat.
This is from France.
It's from MAISON DUTECH.
See?
Notice the collar.
It's not that typical,
you know.
MAISON DUTECH.
OK.
Let's go back to the
phase diagram.
So Dave Broderick is going
to help us here.
So we're going to
have some fun.
I'm going to put on
a face shield so
I don't blind myself.
All right.
Here we go.
So let's get some
liquid nitrogen.
Sounds different, huh?
Sounds terrible for me.
All right.
So we've got some liquid
nitrogen here, and I'll pour
it into a Dewar.
So what happens when you wet a
sheet of paper with ink with
liquid nitrogen?
What kind of bonding is there
in liquid nitrogen?
Look.
No running, no running.
If it's liquid nitrogen.
I tell you, everything you
learn here is so valuable
compared all the other stuff
you learn here--
All right.
So there's a couple of things.
So let's look at glass
transition temperature.
So this is a latex glove.
You can see it's above its glass
transition temperature,
and the cross-links are
snapping it back.
What I'm going to do, is take
it down below its glass
transition temperature, and turn
it glassy and brittle.
So that it's below the TG.
Here's some paraffin.
Paraffin, which is also
a polymer here.
Take the paper off.
OK.
So here's paraffin.
Look.
Look at the van der
Waals bond.
All right?
This is van der Waals bond.
Now we're going to
go below the TG.
It's liquid nitrogen!
It doesn't matter.
OK, you can hear it already.
So it's now below the glass
transition temperature.
So what else have we got?
Oh, you've heard of the glass
flowers at Harvard?
Well, we've got glass
flowers here, so.
Here's a rose.
See, in the proteins, you know,
it's above the-- you
know, it's soft.
But now, we're going
to put the--
mm-hm.
Here we go.
You ready?
Oh, come on.
It's not a kitten.
What's the matter?
It's still burbling here.
We have to wait until
it's dead.
This is for science.
OK.
Now it's below its glass
transition temperature.
Oh, I'm sorry, David.
I should put this over
on the other side.
But maybe it's the red,
or maybe it's
because it's a rose.
So here's the chrysanthemum.
Today is your day.
Let's go.
Get this thing moving!
Yeah.
So there you have it.
There you have it.
I think that's--
oh, there's one, may we
go back to the slide?
Better put the gloves
on for this.
I'll have to write
apology letters.
OK.
So we're going to do next, is
we're going to look at phase
equilibriums.
There's the melting points and
boiling point of oxygen,
argon, and nitrogen.
And what you notice is that
nitrogen boils at a lower
temperature then oxygen
and argon.
So what I'm going to do, is I'm
going to pour some liquid
nitrogen into this beaker.
And then inside the graduated
cylinder, I'm going to let it
sit here, and we're going
to condense air.
And the result will be that
we're going to start
condensing liquid oxygen, and
they'll be little bits of
argon ice floating
in liquid oxygen.
And liquid oxygen is faintly
blue, and it's paramagnetic,
as you know, because it's got
the unpaired electrons, which
means that it will levitate
in a magnetic field.
I couldn't bring a big magnet
in here, but we'll see if we
can make some blue stuff.
And it's foaming, because this
would be like pouring water
into something that's--
I don't know.
300 degrees Centigrade.
But eventually, the heat
transfer gets low enough that
you have stability here, and--
yeah.
OK.
Oh, that's terrific.
What else have we got?
Let's go back to the slide.
God, I hate this thing.
OK.
So you've been looking
at that nitrogen.
Let's look at what's next.
Ah.
Now if you solidify nitrogen
here, you get a whole bunch of
different polymorphs.
Different crystal structures.
So there are about five or six
different crystallographic
forms of solid nitrogen.
For that, we'd have to
bring liquid helium.
4.2 Kelvin.
Very cool stuff.
Here's carbon dioxide.
Now, it also has the positive
slope, so solid
will sink in liquid.
But look, the interesting
point here.
The triple point is
5 atmospheres.
At atmospheric pressure, you go
directly from solid to gas.
It sublimes.
And that's advantageous.
When we use carbon dioxide as
a coolant, when it gives up
its enthalpy to cool, it doesn't
then turn into liquid.
If you chill something with ice,
with water ice, when it
gives up its enthalpy,
the object is
now swimming in water.
And that's no good.
So hence we have the term dry
ice, because we go directly
from solid to vapor.
And we want to prove this.
So what we've got here is
a big block of dry ice.
So this is at minus 78 degrees
Celsius, and it's
still stable here.
Well, it's subliming
before your eyes.
It's smaller than it was when
we started the lecture.
So what I'm going to do now--
oh, I'm not wearing
that stuff.
I guess I'd better.
They're going to write
me up on some log,
teaching you bad practice.
But anyways.
All right.
So what we're going to do, is
we're going to test the
proposal that this actually
goes-- so I've got some water.
Here, David, let's go
out to the video.
So let's take some water.
I think we got water
from France.
Goes with the lab coat.
This is Evian, OK?
So I pour the Evian into
the Florence flask.
This is Florence.
Florence is round, and the
Erlenmeyer is the flat one.
So let's move this guy.
You're going in the backstage
for a while.
You just keep
condensing All right.
So now, this is here.
Now what we're going to do, is
we're going to put some dry
ice in there, and see
if we go directly
from solid to a vapor.
Take a chip off the
old block, here.
OK.
So now you can see that
it's going directly
from solid to vapor.
So that's carbon dioxide
bubbles.
And we assume that the phase
diagrams is correct.
I mean, another thing
we could do, is--
I mean, I know what club
soda tastes like.
I could just test it, right?
Yeah.
It's carbon dioxide.
Now!
Here's the other thing.
You know, Schweppes likes to
pride itself on tiny bubbles.
They have a tagline,
Tiny Bubbles.
Right?
So here's Schweppes.
And you can see Schweppes,
with their
wimpy little tiny bubbles.
Can you get that, David?
But we have, we have
big bubbles.
I mean, this is pure.
You can't get any better
than that.
I got Evian water, and I got
a block of carbon dioxide.
I like making my own
carbonated water.
I've taken it to a new level.
OK.
What else do we have?
Well, let's see if we made
any liquid oxygen here.
Try this.
I don't know if we got
anything here.
Oh yeah!
Oh, wow.
Look.
OK.
So that liquid in there--
oh, I see.
You've got a separate thing.
I don't know if you can see.
It's condensing.
That liquid in there, that's
liquid oxygen.
I won't drink this.
But I can inhale it.
Pure oxygen.
I could have a cigarette,
and just put the
cigarette in there.
What happens if I put the lit
cigarette into the oxygen?
All that happens is that it
burns quickly, that's all.
There's no explosion.
It burns quickly.
If you walk into a room full of
oxygen, all that happens is
you'll singe your nose,
that's all.
There's no explosion.
It's just oxygen.
There's no fuel.
The fuel is just in tobacco,
and there's not much.
It's not a problem.
A room full of oxygen?
Pfft!
OK.
Let's go back to the slides.
What have we got here?
We've got some examples of
other phase diagrams.
All right.
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYBACK: FROM 'PHANTOM
OF THE OPERA']
PROFESSOR: Actually,
it's quite tasty.
All right.
So.
Now, here's zirconia.
Now, here's the thing to
know about zirconia.
Look at all the different
phases.
And cubic zirconia is the one
that has a high index of
refraction, but it's stable only
at temperatures exceeding
2000 degrees C. So
that's no good.
So what I'm going to show you
next day is that by changing
the composition, and adding
calcium oxide, we open up this
zone here that's labeled cubic,
and we get it stable
all the way down to
room temperature.
It's an example of changing
composition to get the
stability of a phase
that we want.
This is carbon.
So down here, the normal form,
as we've learned earlier, the
normal form is graphite.
Diamond is formed at elevated
temperatures and pressures.
And this is liquid carbon.
All right?
Now, to make artificial diamond,
you can try putting
graphite in an anvil, and
squeezing, and squeezing, and
squeezing, and coming
up into here.
And then it becomes metastable,
and then maybe,
because the activation energy
to jump from that sp3
hybridized state to sp2 is so
high, the diamond is stable.
So you don't have to go running
home to see if your
diamond studs are now turning
into graphite.
They won't.
Once you get into this
zone, they'll stay.
The activation energy
is too high.
You need more than 1/40 eV
to do it, is necessary.
But in the 1950s, General
Electric, its Schenectady
research labs, reasoned that
because carbon is so soluble
in iron, they could dissolve
carbon in liquid iron, and
then raise the pressure and
temperature, and then change
to exsolve and cause carbon
to precipitate
out of molten iron.
That's the birth of artificial
diamond.
That's how they did it.
Using this concept, but then
dissolving it in molten iron.
[MUSIC PLAYBACK: 'DIAMONDS ARE
A GIRL'S BEST FRIEND']
PROFESSOR: I don't know
how that got in there.
All right.
Here's one for mercury.
I looked it up, using the tools
that you've been taught
here in 3.091.
So this is a paper phase
diagram for mercury.
And physicists drive me nuts,
because they plot temperature
versus pressure.
I want pressure versus
temperature.
So I just turned it around.
And so here's the liquid line.
So you know that liquid mercury
is going to float on
solid mercury, and there's a
plurality of solid phases.
And these are all different
crystal structures.
Now I've got a treat for you.
I was in Barcelona several
years ago, and I saw the
mercury fountain that was made
by Joan Miro in collaboration
with Calder.
Calder has the big sail outside
of East Campus.
So Calder collaborated
with Miro, back in
the '30s and '40s.
And this is in honor of the
miners of Almaden, where there
are cinnabar mines.
And the miners fought bravely
against the Fascist forces of
Franco, and Miro wanted
to honor them.
So here's their museum.
It's a beautiful place
up on top of an
escarpment over Barcelona.
And what I'm going to show you
is a mercury fountain.
[MUSIC PLAYBACK]
This is liquid mercury.
The speed has not
been altered.
This is a liquid at room
temperature, density 13.5,
metallic bonds.
Look at it.
Very high surface tension.
Look at the way it shimmers.
Look at this shot.
This has not been altered.
That's the way it pours
into gravity field.
It's really fantastic.
And of course, mercury vapor
is toxic, so the
whole thing is in a--
[END MUSIC PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's the--
I cut that snippet out
of the documentary.
OK, we don't want to see that.
So they have the whole
thing inside of a
polymethylmethacrylate cage, to
keep the mercury vapor from
affecting the people that
work in the museum.
Here are some phase diagrams
from hell.
This is bismuth.
And look at bismuth.
Bismuth is like water,
and like silicon.
So the solid is less dense
than the liquid.
But look at all of these
different phases.
Here's sulfur.
Sulfur is crazy.
Look, phases in the solid phase,
there's even phases in
the liquid!
Different phases.
They're allotropes.
Here's sulfur.
Elemental sulfur, the disulfide,
hexasulfide.
It makes rings, it makes
long chains.
And these are called
allotropes.
They're different forms
of the same element.
So oxygen is O. There's
the diatomic molecule.
And the triatomic molecule,
which is ozone, these are all
allotropes of oxygen.
What else do we have?
OK.
This is polymorphs.
So this is alpha goes to beta.
See, different crystal
structures.
You could see with your naked
eye what's going on here.
Different crystal structures.
And then this goes to lambda,
and then finally, they're
pouring here.
And if you get a very high
cooling rate, and you've got
those long chains,
what happens?
You don't form the crystal.
You form the amorphous form.
So they'll call this forming
plastic sulfur.
We know better.
It's amorphous sulfur.
It's not plastic sulfur.
Here's water, a complete
diagram.
Now, this is in kilobars.
So there's all the different
phases of water.
There's the negative line.
That's the thing here.
But at very, very high.
Look at all the different
phases of water.
And they have numbers on them.
If you read Kurt Vonnegut's
Cat's
Cradle, there's ice nine.
You get that going, it freezes
the whole world, right?
But here's, I draw your
attention on this one.
You see this point here?
This is ice seven.
At 100 degrees C, it's solid.
You need 25 kilobars.
So we could go over to the lab,
take some water, put 25
kilobars on it, make solid
ice at 100 degrees C.
And it'll be stable.
Look!
This is minus 78.
It's been here for
a long time.
So now I come into a cocktail
party with this, I drop this
ice cube into a glass of aqueous
beverage, it sinks to
the bottom, and the beverage
heats up to the boiling point.
That's what this
is telling you!
That'll get you popularity
instantly.
How did you do that?
And up here is the supercritical
fluid, the last
thing we haven't said
anything about.
Look.
If you take a gas, and you
keep squeezing it and
squeezing it, eventually the gas
molecules are close enough
together that they're
indistinguishable from the
liquid phase.
Or if you start here, with the
liquid, and you keep raising
the temperature, the density
goes lower and lower until the
molecules are far enough apart
that you can't tell this zone,
whether it's a rarefied liquid
or a highly compressed gas.
The properties criss-cross.
This is supercritical.
It has liquid-like transport
properties, and vapor-like
chemical properties.
So you can end up doing things
that are very, very different.
Now, I'm going to give you an
example of decaffeinating
coffee by taking the coffee,
going up into the
supercritical regime, which
allows you to extract the
caffeine, and not
brew the coffee.
So you want to just get the--
well, if you just heat it up,
you'll make the coffee.
So here's an example.
It's called solvent
extraction.
Historically, this solvent was
methylene chloride, which is
also used as paint stripper.
We don't do that anymore
to coffee.
They did in the '60s!
They did.
They also used
trichloroethylene.
It works really well to leech
out the caffeine.
How much is left in there for
you to taste in your coffee?
I don't know.
Maybe that's why people were
so excited in the '60s to
drink their decaffeinated
Sanka.
I don't know.
But anyway, so you take the
green beans in carbon dioxide
as supercritical, and drop the
caffeine level, and then you
play with temperature and
pressure to go over the KSP.
The caffeine salts out, and
then you recycle the CO2.
OK.
I hope I've given you some
introduction to phase diagrams.
And we'll see you on Monday.